hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and
full power asta has just arrived on the
main battlefield
in time to face off against two of the
strongest devils that we've seen so far
in black clover this means that the rest
of the black bowls
must have arrived as well meaning that
the final showdown
is kicking into high gear the epic
climax is almost here so let's get into
it
if you enjoyed the black clover content
here on the channel and you want to
support the channel for free
just leave a like and comment it really
helps a lot with the youtube algorithm
and like i said it's totally free
and of course if you don't want to miss
videos in the future make sure that you
subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned first up some quick
news
the very first black clover movie has
just been announced we don't have much
info as of right now
but the fact that a movie is being made
is very good news for the franchise
as a whole this means that black clover
is definitely popular and
profitable so i for one was very happy
to hear
this news let me know what you guys
think about the movie announcement down
in the comments
now as the latest chapter kicks off
we're right back
in the present with a severely injured
knocked looking like he's pretty much
done for
as we saw in previous chapters he has
been impaled by lilith and the ma's
magic
and he seems to be incapable of even
moving let alone much else
knocked once again repeats that he
doesn't mind dying
but he refuses to die unless his
sacrifice will contribute to the victory
against these overpowered devils
the four devils that knocked made a
contract with are all
mid-tier which means that they're not
the weakest among the devils but they're
also nowhere near the strength of the
high tier devils
as a result knocked knows that he is at
his limit and
in terms of common sense alone he simply
doesn't stand a chance against
lilith and nama but then knocked things
back to the moment when yami told him
that he was going to start his own magic
knight squad
and yami also said that noct himself
should become his
vice captain this happened right after
morgan's death while nacht was still
trying to recover
from that tragic loss and this was a
meaningful moment because
noct saw the black bulls as an
opportunity for him to atone for his
sins and follow in his brother's
footsteps and honor
morgan's memory however noct has come to
the realization that he can't be like
morgan and he shouldn't try to be like
morgan
noct is a devil host and a shadow magic
user
he is not a shining beacon of light like
his brother was
so knocked must stay true to himself and
fight
evil with evil he must fight darkness
with darkness knocked then takes
inspiration from yami and morgan and he
decides to surpass
his limits he does something that has
never been seen
in the underworld he uses devil unite
with two of his devils
at the same time by uniting with both
plumede
and walgner at the same time knocked
unlocks
yet another new form gallus ex-feliz
this form looks absolutely awesome and
ferocious
and even lilith and ama appear to be
both surprised and impressed
noct then attempts to sacrifice his own
life in order to trap lilith and amma
inside his shadow world forever noct
is hoping that combining the magic of
the two mid-tier devils will make him
strong enough to take down
high tier devils like lilith and ama and
his
plan hinges on the fact that shadows
cannot be burned
or frozen so in theory his shadow magic
should be able to trap the devils
permanently because they won't be able
to use their magic to escape
but shortly after knocked traps the
devils and himself
inside the shadow world lilith and nama
managed to
break out of it it seems that their
magic isn't
just regular freezing and burning no
they have the power of all freezing and
all burning
which seems to mean that they can freeze
or burn through literally
anything and this includes shadows
darkness
light and other things that don't
actually have a physical
substance at this point noct appears to
be utterly defeated
as his new form dissolves and walgoner
and plumandia are reduced to nothing
more than dark puddles
on the floor lilith and emma just laugh
hysterically
and it is clear that they've been
playing around with knocked this entire
time they've just been entertaining
themselves with knocked desperate
attempts to take them down
and now they are absolutely reveling in
his despair
as he realizes that he never stood a
chance against them
this is a truly dark moment for noct
and as the devil's prepared to kill him
noct resigns himself to the fact that
no human can win against the highest
ranking devils
but then seemingly out of nowhere our
boy
osta shows up in the very last second in
his
brand new devil union form and he slices
nama's arm clean off
before the arm can reach knocked as the
highest ranked devils look on in
confusion
asta gets ready to protect his vice
captain with the only power that stands
a chance against
these overpowered devil monsters
and that is of course the power of
anti-magick
and that is how this crazy chapter ends
i think that we were all expecting asta
to show up and fight lilith and nama
eventually
but personally i did not think that asta
would show up so soon
that said this was freaking awesome and
i can't wait to see the new
asta showcasing his latest power-up
against
such strong opponents it was just so
satisfying to see the supremely
confident
lilith and ama being forced to
re-evaluate everything they thought they
knew about humans
after asta shows up asta manages to
actually cut them
as if they were butter which is clearly
shocking
for these two devils noct was on the
verge of complete
despair after his final desperate
sacrifice
ended up being completely futile i think
we were all getting ready to say our
final goodbyes to the black bulls
vice captain but then out of nowhere a
new hope appeared in the form
of devil union asta this was an
absolutely epic moment but don't forget
that this was just the beginning
if asta is here then the other black
bulls that he met up with back in
chapter 283
are now here on the main battlefield as
well
this is it all the major players are now
on the field and so from here on out we
are going
full throttle this is going to be one
crazy showdown
everything is at stake the future of the
entire world is
literally on the line and i can't wait
to see what happens
next with the exception of chibi julius
all of the major characters in the story
are now at full
power including our boy asta and yes we
did technically see asta in action very
briefly when he absolutely wrecked that
ancient demon in like
two seconds but during that brief battle
we definitely didn't see the full extent
of his new power but it looks like we
are about to see the full extent
of his devil union form as he fights
lilith
and namah by the way huge respect to
noct for holding out this long and
keeping these highest tier devils busy
for as long as he did
i mean sure they were just entertaining
themselves with knocked and he was never
a match for them
but the very fact that he survived for
this long gave austin the others enough
time to get to the spade kingdom capital
and now noct can finally take a
well-deserved break
while the others take over hopefully his
injuries
won't be fatal all in all this was so
hype especially when we consider what is
likely coming next
asta the clover kingdom knights the
heart kingdom gang the elves
everyone is at their strongest and
together they will form an incredible
fighting force
but they cannot get cocky because not
only are lilith and ama
absolute monsters but sword the dark
triad morris and all those other devils
who are still
inside the tree of clifforth both sides
in this battle
are absolutely stacked and this is going
to be by far the most
epic clash in the history of black
clover and man
i am here for it let me know what you
guys think are you excited to see
full power that take on lilith and namah
and do you think that he can take them
down before his devil union time runs
out
how do you expect that this final
showdown is going to unfold
and do you think that even stronger
devils like lucifer and lucy fugus are
going to be showing
up anytime soon finally when do you
think that yami is going to get a chance
to join the fight
is he going to remain a hostage until
the end of the arc or do you think that
he will maybe join the fight
at some point i'm sure that his dark
magic would be very useful in this
situation
but either way definitely share your
thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know and if you are new to
anime uproar or maybe watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet do me a
favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications if you don't want to
miss our videos you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying it's multiple
steps
but it's just how youtube works you can
also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord tuigo himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
acquired respect
pate heffa liam thompson algertal dr
cortman
dustin scarlett emperor talk who's
spidey life tonight big
buddhist tungsten tarcus you know
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky cricket xp wrathween
deora
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokamian water joanne garcia the
red-haired raven ted no ted
isparky65 fatboy games deadly saint and
soul race slice and dice if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you